the Trump Bucs are here coronavirus
stimulus checks hit people's bank
accounts yesterday giving much-needed
relief to millions of Americans and the
mainstream media are furious about it
but or left-wing journalists angry about
the policy or they just upset that
President Trump is getting all the
credit then liberal governors give us
even more evidence that the corona virus
pandemic is politically a thing of the
past the government power grab leaves
victims dead in its wake and speaking of
criminals a new report alleges that
Jesse Smollett had sex with his attacker
which is particularly awkward because
Jesse Smollett attacked himself we will
take a broad look at love in the Time of
self-isolation
all that more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
how are you gonna spend your Trump bucks
the money hit everybody's bank account
yesterday the money printer goes burr
and we're hopefully all going to
stimulate the economy the strategy here
behind the Trump bucks is driving the
mainstream media and the left crazy and
it's driving them crazy because he's
stealing their usual strategy and using
it against them so we'll get to that in
one second first I got to thank our
friends over at rain look whether you
own your home or whether you own an
apartment or whether you live in a nice
neighborhood or not so safe neighborhood
you want to have eyes on your front door
let me tell you something I talked to a
friend of mine last night lives in
Manhattan lives in one of the nicest
buildings in Manhattan he woke up the
other day I think about two three weeks
ago he woke up the other day to a
burglar in his bedroom and my friend
like a lunatic kind of chased the guy
out and the guy went out through a
window all because my friend did not
have a decent security system you got to
get ring-ring gives you protection in
every corner video doorbells let you
answer the door and check in on your
home anytime from anywhere okay with
especially these days a lot of people
maybe are not in their homes right now
maybe they're in a different place
people are targeting you full home
security systems give you everything you
need to protect your family pets and
property with outdoor security cameras
you can check in on every part of your
house right now get a special offer on a
ring welcome kit when you go to ring.com
slash knowles kenda wles the welcome kit
includes ring video doorbell three and
chime pro it's all you need to start
building custom security for your home
today go to ring.com slash knowles that
is ring comm slash knowles the trump
bucks hit the bank account and the left
are really upset now wire why are they
gonna even be able to justify how upset
they are they can't actually come out
and say we're upset that americans are
getting relief after the government
mandated that they all stop working for
two months so the way they've got to
express their frustration is to hone in
on this one fact of the stimulus which
is that President Trump's name is on it
here's a reporter
asking that very question why did you
have your name added to these
coronaviruses leave Texas well I don't
know too much about it but I understand
my name is there I don't know where
they're going how they're going I do
understand it's not delaying anything
and I'm satisfied with that I don't I
don't imagine it's a big job I'm sure
people will be very happy to get a big
fat beautiful cheque and my name is on
it yeah go ahead please
a big fat beautiful cheque and my name
is on it
Trump here is stealing a left-wing
political tactic right the left the left
is really good at optics usually they're
very good at making it seem like they
are the ones giving you all these things
all this money all these rights all they
just give give give and they put their
name on it now usually it's not the case
that they're giving you anything they're
just taking your tax money and then
giving it right back to you and saying
it's theirs the left has long done this
now president Trump is using that same
tactic at a time when Americans actually
do need relief but he's flipping their
tactic even in this negotiation don't
forget originally this is a federal
program the Congress and the Senate pass
it so it happens at the federal level
President Trump is running the federal
government the only way that Democrats
would agree to the relief package for
coronavirus is if even though the money
came from the federal government if the
states administered it and now at the
time a lot of people wonder who cares
why would you want to slow down the
process of getting money to people who
need it in this time of unemployment it
doesn't make any sense does it the
federal government can fund it to you
just as easily as the states can but the
reason for that is that the Democrats
did not want Trump to get the credit
even though it was a Trump program even
though it was federally funded so they
went through this whole straw BOTS just
so that they could avoid giving Trump
the credit and what did Trump do he
flipped it back on them and he signed
the checks really smart play he once
again stymied their tactics and of
course people people are not going to
get the check and say mmm I really want
to cash this twelve hundred bucks I
really want to pay off my bills I really
want to pay my rent this month it's got
Trump's name on it I can't cash it no
it's just gonna remind them that this
came from the federal level and give
Trump the credit that he deserves
stymies them on that and then Trump
turns his attention to the Congress
because right now there are a lot of
open positions in the federal government
and some of those need confirmation some
of those need to bring the legislature
in on this but the legislature is not in
Washington you remember the legislature
after a week or two ago they just all
left Washington and went back to their
home districts but they didn't
technically adjourn so there's still
technically in session even though
nobody is in Washington and they don't
intend to come back until May so you if
if the Congress and the Senate do
adjourn then president Trump can appoint
people through what's called a recess
appointment if they don't adjourn then
those people need confirmation and right
now they're in this middle ground where
they haven't technically adjourned but
they're not there so nothing can get
done those positions can't be filled and
obviously we're in the midst of a crisis
so it's more important than ever to get
those positions filled
president Trump figured out a way to
circumnavigate this issue that managed
to make everybody's heads explode he
threatened to adjourn himself both
houses of Congress here's a live feed of
President Trump threatening to close
down both houses of Congress talk of the
exclusion of the Duke of York from the
rightful succession is treason
any who speak of it
set themselves against legitimate
Authority and are the heirs in spirit to
those rebels who so recently plunged our
country into rebellion and civil war can
anyone here contemplate such evil
without aura anyone who denies this
truth makes themselves an enemy of God
king and country think on that before
you take another step towards chaos all
the world may see what a point we have
come to nothing that begins in such
division is likely to end well I declare
Parliament dissolved
gentlemen
go home
I will not trouble you anything
gentlemen go home
okay huge this is going to be the hugest
most wonderful monarchy in the history
of the world I got that was confused
that was actually king charles ii
dissolving Parliament but it was a very
similar clip to President Trump in the
Rose Garden yesterday threatening to
adjourn both houses of Congress and this
is making heads explode and not just on
the left but some heads explode on the
right as well here is and again I'm
sorry for my confusion here is President
Trump the Senate is left Washington
until at least May 4th the Constitution
provides a mechanism for the President
to fill positions in such circumstances
the recess appointment it's called the
Senate's practice of gaveling into
so-called pro forma sessions where no
one is even there has prevented me from
using the constitutional authority that
we're giving that we're given under the
recess provisions the Senate should
either fulfill its duty and vote on my
nominees or it should formally adjourn
so that I can make recess appointments
we have a tremendous number of people
that have to come into government and
now more so than ever before because of
the virus and the problem we have to do
it and we have to do whatever we have to
do if the house will not agree to that
adjournment I will exercise my
constitutional authority to adjourn both
chambers of Congress oh man okay it's
not quite as good as charles ii but it's
very very close if if only if only he
had ended that statement by saying i
will not trouble you any further go home
then it would have been almost exactly
the same the left and some people on the
right are freaking out over this because
they say this is an outrageous
unconstitutional power grab let me
direct your attention to article 2
section 3 of the Constitution the
President may
on extraordinary occasions convene both
houses or either of them and in case of
disagreement between them with respect
to the time of adjournment he may
adjourn them to such time as he shall
think proper he has this authority to
adjourn them he has this power to recess
appointments some people on the Left
don't understand this so Karen Tumulty
over at the Washington Post she tweets
out how do people who used to claim they
respected the Constitution reconcile
this tea party where are you
Tremp Trump threatens to adjourn
Congress to get his nominees through
you're asking how people who respect the
Constitution can go along with President
Trump exercising a power that he has
explicitly granted in the Constitution
that's the question pretty easily I
guess not with without very much
difficulty at all this is my favorite my
favorite version of this so we're
looking up on the internet okay Trump
Trump I guess has this power maybe I'm
miss reading the Constitution doesn't
what do people think about this what
what what do their commentators and the
news people what do they say about this
September 23rd 1964 this is a headline
in the New York Times president has
authority to send Congress home oh I
love it it's it's the same principle as
there's a tweet for everything you know
when President Trump says something
people dig back 10 years in his tweets
and they find a tweet that contradicts
what he's just doing well we can play
that same game with the New York Times
usually we can do that you know month by
month because when a Democrat does
something it's fine and when a
Republican does something it's terrible
in the New York Times we had to go back
a little further here but just go to
1964 New York Times president has
authority to send Congress oh very very
fun Trump obviously knew this his
advisors obviously knew this so yet
again they tee up the left the left goes
crazy and then he just knocks it right
out of the park the rest of the press
conference was good you know obviously
all of these have been pretty
interesting it's allowing Trump to
control the narrative
increasingly they're getting combative
and this is because yesterday we talked
about how the the tide has turned the
backlash has begun this is across party
lines you've now got liberal governors
who are moving away from panic moving
into economic recovery Trump is going on
the offensive more so than usual and
he's going after the reporters and he's
questioning their premises so one of the
premises that the left has been trying
to build up to is that the United States
totally bungled the pandemic and it was
the United States as fault and now we've
got the most coronavirus deaths anywhere
in the world and part of the way they
can get away with this is because China
has been lying about their numbers if
you look at the growth of coronavirus in
China it goes up it goes up it's
increasing steadily it's exponentially
and then one day it just stops okay and
they say Oh more cases we're all good
and that's just not how viruses work the
Chinese government obviously lies all
the time and specifically about this
pandemic their lives are the reason that
spread around the world so no reason to
believe them unless you're in the
mainstream media and you want to attack
Trump so they use this premise and Trump
just shoots it straight down well you
don't know what you have do you think
you're getting honest numbers from some
of these countries do you really believe
those numbers in this vast country
called China and that they have a
certain number of cases at a certain
number that does anybody really believe
that here's the story we report
everything we're reporting the cases and
our reporting is good we're reporting
every death in fact I see this morning
where New York added 3,000 deaths
because they died and they're now saying
rather than it was a heart attack
they're saying it was a heart attack
caused by this so they're adding if you
look at it that's it and everything we
have is documented reported and what
they are doing is just in case they're
calling it this and that's okay that's
okay but we are we have more cases
because we do more reporting we have
more cases because everything is then
but does anybody really believe the
numbers of some of these countries that
you've been watching and you've been
reporting on does anybody believe it no
nobody believes
even the mainstream media doesn't really
believe it they're just saying this to
attack president Trump and on that point
actually Fox News now has multiple
sources confirming something that we
have been talking about for weeks we've
been talking about it not just on this
show I've also been talking about it on
verdict my show with senator Ted Cruz
and when we raised this suggestion the
mainstream media referred to us as
conspiracy theorists without basis and
not just us they did it to Senator Tom
cotton they did it to anybody who raised
the possibility that this pandemic was
in any way connected to the Wuhan
Institute of Virology it's that very
high level virus lab that happened to be
a study in corona virus that happened to
be studying corona virus in bats that
happened to be two miles by car and 800
yards by foot away from the Wuhan wet
market where all this allegedly started
if you suggested any connection between
the two oh you were a kook you were
crazy you had no evidence well now Fox
News is reporting multiple sources
confirm the virus originated in the
Wuhan laboratory it was being studied in
the Wuhan laboratory whether it came at
its inception from nature or elsewhere
it was at that laboratory and it got out
here's the question here's promps answer
multiple sources are telling Fox News
today that the United States government
now has high confidence that while the
corona virus is a naturally occurring
virus it emanated from a virology lab in
Wuhan that because of lack safety
protocols and in turn was infected who
later infected her boyfriend and then
went to the wet market in Wuhan where it
began to spread does that correspond
with what you have heard from well I
don't want to say that John but I will
tell you more and more we're hearing the
story and will say when you say multiple
sources though there's a case where you
can use the word sources but we are
doing a very thorough examination of
this horrible situation that happened
obviously President Trump is giving a
diplomatic answer here because part of
his job is to manage international
relations it's actually why he hasn't
smacked China nearly as hard as you
would
expect him to maybe if you were merely
on the campaign trail part of that is
he's got to work with China right now on
this pandemic part of that is they've
just negotiated this very difficult
trade deal part of that is there are
more factors at play but you can hear in
his answer the subtext is pretty clear
yes there are strong indications that
this came from the lab which frankly is
just common sense okay anybody who has
any reasonable grasp of probability
should have known that this was a very
likely situation this is a humiliation
for the mainstream media who called the
suggestion a conspiracy theory because
they're carrying water for the communist
regime in China and there's more good
news too
we heard yesterday from the liberal
governors and equal moe in New York and
Gavin Newsom in California that things
are looking good they've turned a corner
they want to reopen not just the state
they want to reopen the region that the
political phenomenon of the corona virus
pandemic is over even though obviously
you know medically this is going to
continue for some long period of time as
a political phenomenon as a matter of
the shutdown's it's done there's more
evidence of this today Andy Cuomo
announced in his latest press conference
that things are going so well in New
York even though obviously the death
numbers lag the hospitalization numbers
so the death numbers still might be
pretty scary the hospitalization numbers
are decreasing so steadily that New York
is actually going to be giving away
ventilators to other states on the
ventilators we've stabilized our
healthcare situation New York had one of
the earlier curves there are other
places in this country are now seeing
increases in the death rate and there
seems stress on their healthcare system
I will never forget the generosity that
people of course this country showed to
our state and I said at that time New
Yorkers are generous and they are
grateful and gracious and when you need
help we will be there for you and we
will be state of Michigan is going
through an issue right now state of
Maryland is going through an issue we're
stabilized we're going to send 100
the latest in Michigan and 52 the state
of Maryland now obviously if New York
were still in the peak of this chaos
they wouldn't be able to give away
ventilators don't forget what we had
been hearing for weeks and weeks is New
York doesn't have enough ventilators
doesn't have enough hospitals doesn't we
need to take over the Javits Center we
need to get a cruise ship a hospital
ship down here to take care of everybody
and then that was not needed so there
are fewer people went to the hospital
than they expected fewer people needed
the ventilators than they expected now
they have so much access they're able to
give it away that's in New York the
epicenter of the epidemic in America
great news it's not just in New York
though it's also in California one one
point on any Cuomo though I again was
speaking to a friend of mine from New
York yesterday and he said I I was
watching Andy Cuomo say that New Yorker
is always gracious and grateful and nice
to everybody as Andy Cuomo ever met in
New Yorker and I have to say myself
being in New Yorker I was a little
puzzled at that one thing too that you
notice in these press conferences from
Cuomo he turns up the New York accent so
if you were to listen to him here you'd
hear like hey but you know look this is
New York we're really grateful really
gracious people that's not really how
Andy Cuomo talks I've run into Andy
Cuomo twice in person I was a kitchen
runner I was like a waiter for him one
time when I was in high school and then
one time during hurricane sandy when I
was living in New York I was hanging out
in my apartment building luckily before
Hurricane sandy hit one of our neighbors
had catered an event and brought back I
think 15 cases of beer so we you know
indulged a little bit and then like a
bunch of young idiots in the middle of
the storm went out walking around with
with a beer and a cigar and kind of
survey the damage and the only other guy
we run into out there is Andy Cuomo who
was there with two cops surveying the
damage and anyway I say all of that to
point out he knows how to play it up for
the cameras he's obviously angling for
some kind of national profile here he's
playing up this whole New York character
that's fine that's all well and good if
he could play up the drama of the
situation in New York even more he
certainly would do
that the fact that he's now moving into
this more positive more hopeful angle
means that politically we've turned the
corner gavin newsom is doing the same
thing
gavin newsom is being very very generous
with california's resources meaning with
all of your taxpayer money gavin newsom
is now going to be giving away taxpayer
money to illegal aliens in the state who
are no longer able to work because of
the shutdown he's giving five hundred
dollars per person to one hundred fifty
thousand illegal aliens throughout the
state that's according to the Associated
Press so you're criminal you break our
laws you break very important laws by
crossing our border illegally you remain
here you don't leave and what happens to
you you get up more of our taxpayer
money Wow how generous typical lunacy
from leftist California but I pointed
out to show you if things were really
dire in California if all the doomsday
alarmists were right in California was
just as bad as New York and getting even
worse they wouldn't have the resources
to do this kind of thing but they do
have a lot of extra resources because it
didn't hit nearly as badly as we were
told it was going to so now they're
giving it away to illigal aliens this is
fine evidence that we can start moving
forward but the only way that we're
going to move forward is if you and I
turn up the heat on these politicians
the politicians they're only super
powers they can tell which way the wind
blows we got to make sure that they feel
a strong wind
speaking of criminals by the way you
know part of this whole coronavirus
response is that some local governments
are releasing criminals many local
governments are releasing criminals and
the idea behind it was we don't want the
jail's to be overcrowded we don't want
them to spread coronavirus to each other
we want to in the midst of a crisis
release a bunch of violent thugs onto
the street and that way they can spring
Corunna virus to you as their Bergling
your apartment so typically as you might
expect this did not end very well and
we've predicted on this show I'll point
out that this would not end very well
and now we've got our evidence according
to a Hillsborough County Sheriff's
Office deputies arrested a 26 year old
Joseph Edward Williams for homicide that
happened in Tampa Florida on March 20th
okay but we hear these stories all the
time people commit murder he's facing a
second-degree murder charge along with
resisting an officer with violence felon
in possession of a firearm possession of
heroin and possession of drug
paraphernalia okay so he was arrested
what March 20th the thing that makes
this story notable is that he was also
arrested a week earlier he was arrested
a week earlier on drug charges but they
let him go because coronavirus or
something they let him go
a week later he murders somebody someone
is dead because of their stupid criminal
justice policies in the face of
coronavirus is his victim gonna be added
to the list of coronavirus deaths
probably he should write it because of
the coronavirus response a person is
dead today who would not otherwise have
been dead because this criminal would
not have been led out of prison
these are important data points for
people not just who are defending the
overreaction from the governments here
but who defend letting criminals at a
prison this has become popular even on
the right not just on the left because
on the right they think it's a good way
to pander to voters they say look we
want to let criminals out of at a prison
it's there are too many criminals in
prison never mind what they did never
mind the crimes they committed or or
going to commit we just got to let him
out because it feels icky to lock people
up it's not icky it's a good thing lock
up criminals lock up more criminals you
think we have an over incarceration
problem as long as crimes are being
committed I suppose we have an under
incarceration problem a little bit of
reality coming up against all the models
and the projections and the dreams and
the fantasies speaking of crimes and
fantasies Jessie Smollett is back in the
news how's that for a segue there's a
new report out that Jesse Smollett
apparently this is a little not safe for
work
Jesse Smollett went to a gay bathhouse
in Chicago with his alleged attacker and
had sex with him which is obviously a
little strange because Jesse Smollett
attacked
himself and it reminds me of Woody
Allen's famous line not to knock
masturbation because it is sex with
someone you love I guess what the
article is referring to and the news
report is is referring to is not that
Smollett had sex with his attacker
because he was his own attacker but that
he apparently had sex with the guy who
he paid to pretend to be his attacker
they had a long-standing relationship
they went to this gay bathhouse and all
of this is very possibly going to be
subpoenaed in Jesse smollett's upcoming
trial on charges of disorderly conduct
people are getting a little lonely in
this epidemic okay
speaking of self love people are getting
a little bit lonely there's a study that
just came out foreign ten Americans
right now are lonelier than ever before
a survey of 1055 Americans asked
respondents to answer this question how
is the corona virus affecting you
personally and actually more than four
in ten forty-four percent of them said
that they are now feeling lonelier than
ever before another unintended or
unfortunate consequence of this
coronavirus shutdown maybe it's not
intended but anybody with two brain
cells to rub together could tell
obviously people are gonna be lonely if
you imprison them in their apartments
for months at a time
this has effects on society it will lead
to more suicides it will lead to more
depression it will lead to more drug
abuse it also is a symptom of an
atomized lonely isolated culture a lot
of people especially young people who
would have been married in decades past
are not married right now they don't
have forget about marriage they don't
even have support systems of their own
family or their own local community or
strong friendships that they might have
had in decades past people across
demographics across ages are isolated
not just because the government is
forcing them to stay in their homes but
because of their own behaviors there's a
kind of paradox that comes with this or
a kind of contradiction that comes with
this because we have a culture now where
people are sleeping with a lot of
different people that
more socially acceptable and yet they're
even lonelier the key to this is an
article that was in New York magazine
yesterday what it's like to isolate with
your girlfriend and her other boyfriend
yikes I encourage you to read it it's
like the saddest and funniest article
I've read in weeks I don't know which it
is I think it's both at the same time
but once you get past laughing at this
poor guy and by the way I feel sorry for
every single person in this scenario but
there's actually something profound at
the end of the article so it's an
interview with this guy who hosts a
podcast called the man-whore podcast yes
everybody's got a podcast these days and
he's staying at his girlfriend's
apartment that she has with her other
boyfriend and they're like sharing the
girlfriend and it's a very creepy and
weird then once you get past all the
effeminacy and sadness he he gets to his
line which shows you a kind of
selfishness here he says there's part of
me that's relieved that megan has
another person here because then I don't
have to be everything to her I don't
have to give her all the attention
that's needed I don't have to give her
all of the cuddles that are needed
because she has another partner in
general that's the really cool thing
about polyamory I don't feel the
pressure of being everything for someone
wow what an amazing line that is I don't
feel the pressure of being everything
for someone and in a more stressful time
like this it's a relief to know that if
I need to have some alone time
she's good with that and if she doesn't
have a need she can tap somebody else so
to speak yuck gross sad pathetic the
flaw in this guy's reasoning is this
error that we have in our society we
believe as the society has become more
materialistic that the way to have a
good fulfilling happy life is to pursue
our own desires and to pursue our own
appetites forget about all that
old-timey stuff that restrains your
desires and tells you that you can't do
everything you want to do whenever you
want to do it get rid of that man break
free liberate yourself and then you know
if you have a
girlfriend and she's got three
boyfriends and then you've got six
girlfriend that'll be so good because
you don't have responsibility this is
the mistake they're making they think
that responsibility makes you unhappy
and a lack of accountability makes you
really happy but actually that's not
true I know it seems true that's what
every young person has ever thought who
resists marriage who resists commitment
who resists getting a job but actually
nobody is gratified when they go home
and look at porn and stuff their faces
and drink too much and lie on the couch
and don't accomplish anything that makes
you depressed that makes you sad makes
you into a loser if however you give of
yourself you sacrifice some of yourself
you care about other people you do
things that you don't want to do because
it's the right thing to do you take on a
job you take on the responsibilities of
a family it seems like that would make
you less happy actually it makes you
much more gratified in life there is a
phenomenon that I've just learned about
called only fans have you heard about
this only fans is a level of pornography
a level of debauchery that I'm very
grateful that I've I've never been
exposed to of all the debauchery have
been exposed to somehow I was able to
avoid that one only fans is this website
where you log on and you you have to pay
like 10 or 20 bucks a month to subscribe
to a person who is a homemade porn store
someone there's no it's the total
democratization of porn
no more gatekeepers that girls log on
and they say I'm gonna become an only
fan performer and then the guys log on
and they pay or ten twenty however much
per month and you get access to photos
and some some are very banal right just
updates about their day for some of
these girls they don't even take their
clothes off they that you they kind of
racy pictures but you don't they don't
take their clothes off it's it's
actually that you're paying not for the
naked photos you're paying for the
semblance of a relationship how sad is
that
because obviously there are a zillion
naked ladies on the internet you can
look on the internet for free without
putting down a credit card and see
anything that you want to see any sick
thing that you can imagine I
promise you it's out there this is one
of the laws of the internet and yet
people are paying money to see
oftentimes not naked women and what
they're paying for is to feel as though
they've got some kind of relationship
with this person that is the height of
decadence that is the height of
debauchery it's it's probably of
although a dark weird kinds of porn on
the internet
this might be the darkest one because it
it reflects a society that's now so
isolated that's become so alienated from
itself that it can't even have a normal
platonic relationship or a normal
flirtatious relationship you actually
have to pay for that now you don't need
to pay to see weird sex you do have to
pay to feel any human connection that is
not a problem of isolation only in
quarantine that is a much bigger problem
it's gonna last longer than the
coronavirus does that is for sure okay
we gotta get to the mailbag first though
I've got an excellent deal for you when
you become a daily wire insider plus or
all-access remember you will get two of
the incredible magnificent left is tears
tumblers not one one is good - where'd
they go - much much better this is very
important because if you're Joe Biden
you're probably gonna lose your leftist
yours tumbler you're just not gonna
remember where you placed it but if you
have to then you can keep them and if
your Joe Biden you can give one to your
imaginary friend corn pop you get all
this great stuff you know what you get
you get all the shows you get all access
you get you just get everything the only
wire that comes / subscribe get started
to get 10% off additionally with promo
code Knolls that's daily wire.com /
subscribe coupon code Knowles get the
rarest of beverage vessels x - we'll be
right back with the mailbag
I am going to fly through this mailbag
because as usual I'm running late from
Matt austere religious podcaster and
Lord of the cough FA you seem to be a
student of both Dante and ancient Rome
as such my question involves both namely
does Brutus deserve his place in Dante's
hell alongside Judas thanks for the
great show and keep up the good work
came for Ben
stayed for Michael yes Brutus is the guy
who was friends with Caesar who murders
Julius Caesar and in Dante he's
represented in the absolute lowest pit
of hell which is a lake of ice in which
Satan is trapped
Satan is a three-headed monster and in
his teeth in his each of his jaws he's
chewing brutus and Kassius who killed
Caesar and Judas who killed Christ
Brutus does deserve his place in Hell
Brutus is sometimes considered a good
person because he tried to stop the
tyranny of Caesar and he tried to defend
the Republic the reason that Brutus
deserves his place in the lowest level
of Hell is that he betrayed his
benefactor he betrayed his friend and
that is the worst possible crime you can
commit you know in Dante's hell you got
the early kind of fleshly sins those are
in the upper layers of Hell it's not as
not quite as painful and then you get
down lower and lower to the worst sins
and and the worst sins you get to are
the sins of fraud or the sense of
betrayal they're the worst things that
you can possibly do and the people who
engage in fraud and betrayal for
instance of their benefactors they
deserve the absolute worst punishments
that there are from Joshua Michael my
state of Minnesota issued a lockdown and
extended it until name although I do
believe in public health as an exception
to normal government rules how long can
a lockdown go on before we reach 1984
levels of government intrusion
I love the podcast this long that's how
long exactly this long and now it's gone
too far okay when you're arresting
pastors but letting criminals out onto
the streets so they can go murder people
which is actually happening you have
gone too far when the models that you
were using were all shown to be
incorrect and then you respond to that
by doubling
down and adding more draconian measures
and threatening to fine or jail people
for not following those measures like is
happening here in Los Angeles you have
gone too far these people have been
overstepping their vents when the police
come out and say you no longer have a
First Amendment right to protest because
protesting is a non-essential activity
the government has gone too far and now
is the time to push back from Michelle
can you speak to the report the 3,700
deaths were just added to the death
count in New York without testing for
coronavirus how is this allowed to
happen can someone ask dr. Burks or
fowey how can we stop this that did
happen in New York just the other day
deaths that had obviously already
happened which did not include a test
for coronavirus were added to the death
count in New York now the defense of
this is that perhaps there weren't tests
available they weren't able to determine
with certainty whether or not these
people had coronavirus but it seems
likely that they did so they're gonna
add it to the death camp the argument
against this is this is BS to pad the
death numbers and to take a more liberal
counting view to use dr. Burks his own
terms
coronavirus is very difficult to take a
look at the deaths because the victims
are so overwhelmingly old and they so
overwhelmingly have comorbidities and so
let's say you die of a heart attack did
you die of a heart attack or did you die
of coronavirus let's say you have stage
4 lung cancer and you've got three weeks
to live but you died one week into that
because you also have corona virus did
you die from corona virus or from the
lung cancer most of us would say the
lung cancer but it is complicated
because the corona virus hastened your
death
increasingly all the politicians are
going to be taking the broader view of
what counts as a corona virus death that
I think has very little to do with
medical science has a lot to do with
politics because they've got to defend
their decision to shut down the global
economy and throw twenty million people
out of work nobody is going to want to
turn that around because all of the
political incentives for these
politicians are to have the larger
defensible number rather than the
smaller more conservative number from
Michael hi Michael what is your
perspective on human nature oh just that
small topic does your view primarily
stem from religious beliefs philosophy
or both how do these views shape your
ideas on the role of government
personally I find myself agreeing with
John Calvin's idea of toe
depravity and with Thomas Hobbs that
people will always act in self-interest
Thanks
well it I don't think we can just
narrowly say my view of human nature
comes from philosophy or my view comes
from religion my view of human nature
comes from my eyes and my brain ok I see
people I interact with people I talk to
people and I think about how that works
and I try to make sense of it that's
that's what we all do I do not agree
with John Calvin's view of human nature
John Calvin's view of human nature is
called total depravity it's the idea
that human beings are totally utterly
completely depraved so I don't agree
with that I don't believe that is true
if you do agree with that and as you say
you agree with Thomas Hobbes and other
political thinkers along that line and
certainly you could not support the
American government or self-government
because people are totally depraved so
they're absolutely unqualified to to
govern themselves now on the other hand
I also don't support the bright-eyed
bushy-tailed idealistic view of human
nature that human nature is mostly for
99% good you know obviously there are
some bad things now it again but really
we're all just fine and dandy I don't
believe that is true either
I support the middle view of things
which is that man is made in the image
of God which is good and man is fallen
through the abuse of his free will which
is bad I believe in original sin I think
that sin and death pervade the world and
all of us commit sins and we can commit
very very bad sins and we can look
really wrong and bad and perverted also
we have a goodness that comes to us
which is why human beings obviously
don't only act in self-interest when an
old lady's about to get hit by a bus and
a young person runs out there and goes
to sacrifice himself for her which
situations like this happen all of the
time
genuine selflessness that cannot be
explained by men always acting in their
own self-interest so that's just a sort
of narrow I think cartoonish ideological
view the real answer as is often the
case is in that middle way which takes
into account both
of those things you could see the same
thing when it comes to questions of
grace and freewill is also I guess you
could bring John Calvin and for this as
well do we not have any free will at all
everything is totally predestined and
predetermined and and forget just John
Calvin even these Silicon Valley
nincompoops who say that free will is
merely an illusion
and we're just kidding ourselves is that
the case well on one that seems false
but on the other extreme is it the case
that there's no such thing as grace no
such thing as Providence the only hope
we have is to save ourselves and to act
according to our own will no that's
obviously not true either
the real answer is this middle way which
is that will and grace not the 90s TV
show but the facts of existence Will and
Grace exists together in a mystery that
is sort of like two people dancing a
waltz from Jackson Yorick OFA my wife is
pregnant with our first child and I
refuse to send him to public school so
one of us will have to stay home her
work will pay off her student loans so
she has to stay there my problem is that
I don't want her to have the
responsibility of being the main income
is there a problem with me staying home
I still want to work even if it's a
night job well I don't think there's a
problem necessarily it sounds like you
think there's a problem because you want
to work and if you want to work you
should work you're not gonna have to
worry about this problem for what five
years until kindergarten
I guess now people send their kids to
school quote unquote when they're like
six months old but that's ridiculous
right that's just a way to make you feel
better about sending a kid to daycare so
you know you've got a little bit of time
here right it's so funny I mean when I
was in school I went to kindergarten my
father didn't even go to kindergarten he
went to he just started in first grade
then when I was a kid we started in
kindergarten I didn't go to preschool or
anything now kids it seems like they
start going to school at 1 year old or
you know sometime around there but you
don't need to do that so maybe someone
stays home for the first few years and
maybe you work a night job maybe you
work a job that can be done from home
one thing we're learning from quarantine
is there are a lot of jobs that you can
do from home not just ecommerce which is
the most obvious one or not just you
know certain just many other jobs in
many different sectors in many different
industries now we're finding out you can
do things that we thought previously
we're not poss
to do from home from home things like
education there was online learning but
the vast majority of education happened
in schools now all education is being
done online that's probably going to
transform that sector as well so I would
try to get creative about it because I
agree with you mankind is meant to work
and raising a kid is a lot of work but
if you're a little bit more
traditionally minded and you think it's
odd for a father to stay home all the
time and not do anything else other than
raise kids then that's fine I would
pursue that you don't want to get into a
situation where you resent your wife or
resent your kid because you're doing
something that feels totally unnatural
to you from Nick on all access you
basically summed up Yoga is giving the
devil a lap dance did I that sounds more
pithy than what I said but I'll go with
it other than the annoying amount of
time that those who do yoga talk about
it as Christians what is so wrong in
doing awkward stretches thanks the
problem isn't the awkward stretches the
problem is that Yoga is a spiritual
practice it's a Hindu liturgy and that's
why you always hear yoga teachers
they're not just talking about the weird
stretches they're talking about energy
and mantras and you know the solar
plexus and the and when you get to the
really weird ones they talk about like
crystals and things like that and it's a
new-agey weird religion so if you want
to do stretches go do Pilates or just
stretch I think it's a good idea I've
done yoga in my life and the stretching
feels pretty good but the weird
religious symbolism and chants and
mantras that go along with it don't feel
very good if you don't happen to be a
part of that religion so I would avoid
pairing up those two things and just go
for a stretch stretches are a little
less sexy and a little less hip and less
cool but it will do exactly the same
thing for your body and might have a
better effect on your soul okay um you
know we have so many more questions but
we're out of time
as always I'm gonna be filling in for
the Ben Shapiro radio show though so you
will get hours and hours more for us to
hang out we're gonna be taking your
calls there as well so tune in for when
that's going to be and in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you